Marie-Josée Paquette Comeau.
- Le Quartier chinois
de Montréal esrorororoie
à l'embourgeoisement depuis
plusieurs années, ce qui
représente une sérieuse menace
à son pinininine.
TAIKA BAILLARGEON, dir. adjointe
des politiques Héritage Montreal
- C'est un quartier qui, c'est
ça, subit beaucoup de pression
immobilière, donc on sentait
vraiment l'urgence d'agir.
- C'est pourquoi Québec
intervient pour protéger
le Quartier chinois.
Le coeur du Chinatown est
en voie d'être classé comme
site patrimonial, dont
deux bâtiments : l'édifice de
lashshshsh and Canadian School,
connu comme étant la maison
Wing, et l'ancienne manufacture
S. Davis and Sons.
NATHALIE ROY, ministre de la
Culture et des Communications
- La protection extérieure
de ces bâtiments protégera
notre patrimoine et permettra
à la communauté de faire vivre
ses lieux emblématiques.
- Avec ses légumes et sa
médecine traditionnelle,
le quartier est plus qu'une
accumulation de commerces.
C'est l'âme d'une communauté,
une histoire de l'immigration,
un pouls depuis plus de 120 ans.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- On dit à ceux qui habitent
le Quartier chinois et qui y
tiennent, à cette identité-là :
inquiétez-vous pas!
- Mais certains s'inquntntntntnt
quand même. La portion préservée
ne touche que le coeur du
quartier. C'est pourquoi
la Ville de Montréal a adopté
une résolutionmimimimimiter
immédiatement les hauteurs
et la densité permises
dans ce secteur.
- Pour s'assurer que le
déveimimimimimimmobilier
se fasse de façon harmonieuse.
WINSTON CHAN, Comité pour la
relance du quartier chinois
- Je pense que c'est une bonne
lelelelelele pour... un bon prer
pas pour pouvoir préserver l'âme
du Quartier chinois.
- Copapapapapapart des membres
de sa communauté, il se réjouit,
mais demeure sur ses gardes.
- Oui, on espère que ce n'est
pas un Disney Land où est-ce que
l'extérieur, c'est chinois,
mais que l'intérieur, il y a un
McDonald's ou un Starbucks.
Donc, l'important, c'est
e e e e e e préserver l'âme du
quartier chinois.
JEAN-PHILIPPE RIOPEL,
résident du quartier chinois
- Il ne faut pas que
l'on conserve seulement que
les façades. Pourquoi?
Parce que ce patrimoine-là,
dans le quartier chino
il est toujours vivant.
- La Ville de Montréal soutient
que ce n'est qu'un premier geste
pour préserver et revitaliser
leinininininininois.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau